East Room for sure an affluent suburb to
the south of Glasgow once voted the
second best place in Britain to bring up
a family up until 20 years ago this was
the safest conservative seat in Scotland
but labour celebrated victory here in
their 1997 landslide 18 years later it
was the Nationalists who tasted a win in
2015 two years later the Conservatives
came around again so who will be
charging their glasses this time in a
closely fought race in this election and
in this seat the SNP is on the March
many people here is deeply concerned but
leaving the EU and unconvinced by Boris
Johnson or Jeremy Corbyn
but in a seat people voted to remain as
part of the UK with this election be
more about breakfast or independent the
SNP are confident that their clear
message and what they see as the big
issue at the election will win them the
seat back so when you're out door
knocking then what are the big issues
that people are talking about it's
breaks it breaks it comes up on almost
every doorstep that we go to here in
Easter I'm for sure people are extremely
concerned about what's been going on in
Westminster and do you think that that
is perhaps what gives you a better
chance of taking the thing I think it's
it's something that certainly resonates
with the voters all sources
kids the Conservatives are out in force
but speaking to the candidate are
detected a certain nervousness I think
this seat will be I think certainly be
closer than it was in 2017 and for us
it's just about getting out talking to
voters reassuring those that might be
wavering and then critically finding
those people who didn't vote
conservative in 2017 but I believe in
Scotland's place in the Union and
faithfully just asking them to lend us
their vote this time around to stop the
SNP while labour are relying on their
core policies but concede there is a
problem with the stance on independence
Jeremy Corbyn has not ruled out the idea
of granting a second referendum on
Scottish independence is that a problem
for you
Scotland's had that independence
referendum we've had that decision read
was Stevie 40 to stay in the United
Kingdom and in East Renfrewshire as I
mentioned Ellis 63% forty to stay in the
United Kingdom that's massive
so we doing it another divisive
referendum so what did the voters make
of it all honestly undecided
yeah vocationally voice in conservative
so afraid of hard not devote that every
single one of them I think you know
laughter the one thing this money hours
are I remain devoted to leave so I'm a
Democrat I think I said I would leave
because of all but if they made up like
backs ad everything that's isolated on
in a moment
in Scotland a very different election
campaign is being fought to the rest of
the UK
not just on brexit but also independence
making it more unpredictable to work out
where the floating voters will settle so
here in Sky News is Russia